[Musica]
ciao sono valentina e ho 17 anni
da quattro anni assieme alla mia
famiglia stiamo combattendo una lotta un
po impari siamo spesso in ospedale per
papa
adesso ho paura però ho paura perché
vedo mia mamma sempre più spesso in
ospedale con lui a volte ci vado anch'io
ma non sempre perché non servire a nulla
e sarei solo d'impaccio
ogni volta che papa torna a casa è più
stanco della volta precedente e quella
volta quando è uscito di casa non è
proprio è più tornato siamo rimasti io e
mamma come facciamo adesso
come sarà la nostra vita senza di lui
ecco all'inizio è stato difficile ea
volte lo è anche adesso perché è un
dolore grande molto grande che con il
tempo si attutisce ma non passa mai del
tutto io e mamma assieme abbiamo
ricostruito delle abitudini dei ricordi
e delle quotidianità
lei è diventata il mio punto di
riferimento il mio faro nel buio mi ha
fatto da mamma e da papa ha fatto quello
che di solito fanno in due
ma da sola e ha scelto di essere molto
coraggiosa ma io io da sola mela saprò
cavare pur convivendo con tutto quello
che è successo
ecco non subito ma decido di ripartire
da lì dal luogo in cui tutto è finito un
giorno per caso in università trovo un
volantino pubblicizza la serata di
presentazione di un gruppo di persone
che entrano in ospedale con un naso
rosso
cos'è mi incuriosisce ma mi intimorisce
anche un po all'inizio così deciso di
andarci a questa serata di presentazione
ecco credo che nulla venga per caso
quindi in qualche modo quel volanti non
avrei trovato lo stesso prima o poi da
quella sera la mia vita cambia di nuovo
capisco che posso ancora trasformare le
lacrime in sorrisi e che non mando
non posso mandare via il dolore più
grande che abbia mai provato ma lo
accolgo e scelgo di trasformarlo in
qualcosa di nuovo e in qualcosa di bello
ciao sono una dottoressa gambalunga e
non importa quanti anni abbia dopo un
lungo percorso di formazione in cui ho
lavorato con valentina siamo di nuovo
entrata in ospedale di nuovo quel luogo
che tanto dolore aveva portato ma
stavolta siamo riusciti a trasformare in
sorrisi ed è questo che fa il clown
dottore quando entro in una stanza cerca
di cambiare nell'umore con la presenza
con le gag e anche con le bolle che
hanno un potere magico a qualunque età
ecco in questi anni di lavoro assieme
abbiamo visto delle belle con valentina
però all'inizio non è stato così facile
volerci bene infatti lei non era proprio
così contenta di dover mettere a nudo le
sue emozioni per conoscersi ma poi
grazie anche all'aiuto dei formatori che
l'hanno seguita in tutto il percorso è
riuscita a scoprirmi mia vista e ha
visto le mie caratteristiche
assieme abbiamo anche scelto un costume
no non è questo il primo costume che
abbiamo scelto ma è questo come cambia e
cresce valentina cambio e cresco anch'io
inoltre in ospedale non andiamo mai da
soli
siamo sempre in due perché così ci
supportiamo e ci aiutiamo se io non ho
un idea mi può dare un'idea il mio
collega e magari i bambini non hanno
voglia di giocare con noi e quindi noi
possiamo giocare e loro ci possono
guardare
sapete stai in ospedale per chi è
costretto a starci non è per niente una
bella esperienza perché c'è chi ti dice
sempre cosa devi farlo e quando c'è un
medico che ti visita e può anche darsi
che tu provi dolore
allora almeno quando ci siamo noi
possono decidere loro se giocare con noi
oppure solo guardarci
insomma quando ci siamo noi possono fare
la loro
la scelta è così come possono fare ai
bambini ha fatto valentina la scelta di
prendere me gambalunga per accogliere e
trasformare il suo dolore
ciao sono valentina più a 27 anni
vedo che avete avuto il piacere di
conoscere gambalunga
lei è parte di me della mia vita ne è
quella parte di me che mi dà la
possibilità di fare le scivolate nel
corridoio di pediatria senza paura che
mi sgridano è quella parte di me che mi
fa fare mille bolle pur bagnando il
pavimento è quella parte di me che
osserva stupita la reazione di ogni
bambino che si trova davanti ed è quella
parte di me da cui ho imparato che c'è
sempre una via d'uscita c'è sempre un
modo diverso di vedere la stessa
situazione
e c'è sempre un modo per affrontare
tutto anche il dolore più grande e con
mia mamma
in questi dieci anni di vita assieme ci
siamo date il tempo di ricostruire il
nostro rapporto
ci siamo conosciute meglio e abbiamo
accettato anche i nostri angoli più
spigolose ecco quando vi trovate nel
buio quando non sapete da che parte
guardare e non trovate la luce non
arrendetevi non datevi per vinti
aguzzate la vista e scegliete forse non
sarà un conduttore
forse non sarà un insegnante ma qualcosa
sarà sicuramente date ad ognuno di voi
la possibilità di trovare la vostra
gambalunga che vi aiuti i supporti e vi
alleggerisca la vita e perché no magari
che vi permetta anche di fare del bene
agli altri facendo vi star bene grazie
[Applauso]